[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
nem eu
todo o entulho
a franquia tem uma camisa do milan ser
uma prenda de natal
[Música]
boa tarde galera tudo bem eu tenho uma
história pra contar pra vocês em meu
nome é flávio bem em 2017 os ônibus e
terminais da rede metropolitana de
curitiba foram invadidas por vídeo artes
como essa que vocês acabaram de assistir
essas ação fez parte da bienal
internacional de arte digital e contou
com a presença de três vídeo artistas
dois internacionais e um nacional local
naquele curitiba é essa exposição durou
quatro meses dentro dos ônibus e
terminais alguém porém chegou a conferir
isso entre 2017 e 2018 12345 legal o que
vocês acharam legal divertido mais ou
menos tá beleza qual é a idéia por trás
disso tudo
a idéia era justamente tirar extrapolar
os limites da da exposição física e
levar essa ache para a maior parte das
pessoas para onde essas pessoas estão na
onde a maior parte das pessoas estão que
são dentro dos nas ruas dentro dos
ônibus terminais
em maio essa expressão foi mais
específico dentro dos ônibus e e
terminais a gente fez um levantamento na
galeria de arte ea gente descobriu que
cerca de 80% do público que viu a
exposição na galeria é porque tinha
visto dentro dos ônibus e isso na
verdade chocou a gente que a gente não
esperava todo esse tipo de de público lá
na galeria
então a gente as pessoas que chegavam lá
elas tentavam entender aquilo que elas
estão assistindo e elas perceberam que
elas falavam pra gente que não entende
nada de arte tecnologia mas ou pensava
que não achava que entende né
mas quando a gente faz uma pergunta pra
elas sobre o que elas estão dispensados
aquilo a gente descobre que elas têm um
enorme potencial e
dentro desse potencial é a gente achou
que elas têm algum tipo de bloqueio
neste momento e ao mesmo tempo elas é
simplesmente foram chamados para preciso
e ventos sentir um chamado para ir para
lá nesse evento
então é foi uma das coisas em que mais
marcou gente nesse tipo de situação
é bom fazer um flashback aqui em 2012 eu
finalizei me concluir uma especialização
em sinais reais de ensino das artes aqui
em curitiba
'ela desenvolvi minha poética artística
pra quem não sabe poética é todo o
trabalho do artista é desde a parte de
pesquisa da parte de um processo de
criar aí a divulgação e também é parte
de exposição da obra e então esse
trabalho todo eu acabei divulgando é
lembrado pra festivais no mundo todo e
esse trabalho também eu comecei a
questionar porque que o meu trabalho era
selecionado nesses nesses lugares é o
que fazia o meu trabalho selecionado
quais são os critérios
então aquilo ficou na minha cabeça do
chile num canto e aí eu fiz um
levantamento entre 2010 e 2017 cerca de
três exposições de arte digital unha de
forma coletiva e internacional aconteceu
em curitiba nesse período eu achei que
isso é muito pouco
então eu imaginei que eu precisava fazer
alguma coisa eu entrei numa busca por
uma resposta depois disso e ainda no
final de 2016
eu descobri que existia uma bienal
internacional de arte digital e lá eu
acabei entrando em contato com o
idealizador do evento
lá ele estava fazendo chamadas abertas
para curadores e eu pensei eu acho que
eu posso entrar nesse lugar porque o
acre
porque de repente dá para fazer alguma
coisa em curitiba
então eu conversei com o idealizador do
evento
fiz umas perguntas pra ele eu perguntei
pergunta número um o que eu preciso para
que esse evento aconteça na cidade
aí ele foi monossilábico e falou pra mim
vontade eu pensei tá beleza que vontade
eu tenho aqui um lugar em um canto do
deus tenho vontade beleza pergunta
número 2
qual é a verba que eu tenho para
realizar esse evento aqui na cidade
ele falou nenhuma
você precisa se virar vai lá atrás e
precisa correr atrás de patrocinador
trás do apoio vai lá e aí eu pensei humm
agora faz sentido vontade lado a
primeira pergunta e em terceiro fiz uma
pergunta técnica
você precisa ver meu currículo e
portfólio
aí ele falou não não vai perceber leza
aí então ele já emendou ele falou
parabéns você está na bienal
internacional de arte digital seu
embaixador em curitiba
então assim foram três perguntas assim e
já tô dentro como assim né
foi uma das coisas meio maluca assim
porque eu não esperava é essa abertura
sintam tão simples e ao mesmo tempo eu
isso depois é virou história no final
das contas porque acabou acontecendo uma
bienal internacional de arte digital
aqui em curitiba em 2017 e 2018 que foi
numa galeria de arte com dez artistas
cinco nacionais e cinco internacionais é
uma parte da exposição foram dentro dos
ônibus e terminais com três vídeos
tintas e também é
teve dois oficinas 2 bate papos meses e
bate papos e ea isso aconteceu né
mas se uma das coisas engraçadas super
curiosas no no evento lá que estava
acontecendo na exposição dentro da
galeria
chegou uma senhora de 60 anos de idade
chegou na galeria e ela ficou
maravilhada com tudo o que estava vendo
ela achou que aquilo era uma coisa assim
espetacular que ela nunca tinha visto
aquilo que ela estava muito nestas e
observando e tocando nas obras e teve
uma hora que ela falou pra gente aí eu
não entendo nada de tecnologia
ah então você vê que é uma daquelas
pessoas da estatística na e aí o tc não
tem problema nenhum você pode aqui fica
aqui fruindo curtindo e depois ela falou
da gente fez uma pergunta para ela um
dia que você viu sobre essa exposição
aqui
ela falou dentro dos ônibus a olha só
mais uma da estatística é e legal né
e aí ela foi cut vale e tal e ela chegou
no trabalho do artista croata estava no
computador e no trabalho que você
acessar a web para poder entrar acessar
o mundo dessa artista e ela falou que
ela não sabia mexer no computador e
aquilo pensei não vai ser daqui sem
tocar no computador
ela nem sempre fluir no trabalho da
artista
não vou deixar e aí entrou o meu lado
arte educador
eu peguei na mão dela pacientemente fui
explicar como funcionava o computador a
linguagem primeiramente falei da
linguagem do computador
fiz umas perguntas pra ela pra entender
o universo dela com relação aquilo tudo
foi revelando e até chegar no momento
que ela ficou familiarizado com o
computador e explique um pouco da
poética do artista mas também não
explique muita coisa de um passo para
trás
e observando ela estava mexendo lá e tal
um pouco tempo ela já estava normalizada
e aí ela tava dando risada mais alto e
aquilo foi um crescendo e ela começou a
se divertir realmente ela parecia uma
criança e eu pensei nossa como assim
olha que o outro um pouco tempo uma
questão de 15 minutos ela estava
completamente absorvida ali naquele
trabalho
depois de um tempo vou sair dali acho
que ela já estava cansado além daquele
trabalho que era muito maluco e aí ela
foi para um outro trabalho que é do
artista local há no rock de verdade
virtual
a gente colocou óculos nela e e aí eu
pedi para ela sentar porque
eventualmente as pessoas ficam tontos
com experiência
esse trabalho assentou e botou óculos
ela ficou estática e aí eu saí dali fui
para um canto
aí passou um minuto ela está exatamente
no mesmo lugar exatamente igual eu
pensei que ia acontecer alguma coisa ela
não está se conectando com o trabalho
sei lá voltou desligado ou não sei fui
cheguei perto dela e aí sorrateiramente
falei no pé do ouvido dela
ó você pode virar a cabeça você quiser
ela virou a cabeça
foi uma coisa incrível ela claro que não
tem todas as válvulas assim mas é ela é
simplesmente ela saiu em êxtase dali ela
viu que existe todo um universo dentro
daquele cyber espaço uma performance do
artista e ela ficou maravilhada ela saiu
dali tiro já tirou aquilo ali
o óculos e foi abraçando todo mundo que
estava lá na equipe neco é cumprimentou
todo mundo em êxtase e ao mesmo tempo
foi é é uma sensação que ninguém
esperava a reação dela e ela falou toda
entusiasmada meu deus eu preciso
apresentar expressei minhas amigas e 60
anos de idade também
em que não tem como não tem relação com
as tecnologias
é preciso trazer elas realmente eu não
sei se ela foi lá depois é eu tenho
gostaria de saber se ela ver isso aqui
um dia para poder entrar em contato
porque foi uma das experiências mais
legais que a gente teve eu sei que ela
saiu dali e ela não era mais a mesma
pessoa
ela foi transformada de alguma forma e
eu naquela noite eu lembro que eu fui
deitar na cama e eu dormi com um sorriso
no rosto
sabendo que eu tinha feito alguma coisa
não sabe exatamente aqui mas é uma coisa
boa
então o que eu posso aprender o que
aprendi com isso tudo número 1 eu ganhei
uma ferramenta e essa ferramenta se
chama empatia
não que eu não aplicar a simpatia no dia
a dia mas eu percebi o quão importante é
isso eu percebi ali naquele naquela
experiência de poder contar 11 explicar
um tema super complexo e de luiz uma
forma simplificada e ao mesmo tempo eu
percebo que isso também é um gatilho
para a gente se espalhar isso pra o
número de pessoas número 2
eu sentir uma enorme vontade de mexer na
engrenagem da cultura curitibana e eu
sinto que vocês aqui dentro e as pessoas
lá fora são o meu combustível
nós precisamos uns dos outros para que a
transformação aconteça
3 eu tenho um primeiro passo e eu sair
da inércia e ouvir que com esse é essa
atitude este ato a gente consegue mudar
o o holocausto e modifiquei meu local e
teve um impacto mundial
e eu pergunto pra vocês
será que vocês não podem sair da inércia
também
experimente sair nessa tem um primeiro
passo
só faço essa essa exclamação aqui pra
vocês meio que um questionamento
eu acho que vocês não têm nada a perder
com isso tudo bem meu mundo eu
transformei através da tecnologia e o
mundo de vocês como vocês gostaria de
transformar em piada
[Aplausos]